the world breaking clash between
History's Strongest being and the
strongest Sorcerer of the modern era
just got even crazier Saturday is this
close to proving that he is the
strongest ever and that even sukuna must
fall under the power of unlimited void
but sukuna has a devious trick up his
sleeve both men are going all out both
are feeling the effects of this
superhuman struggle on their body but
only one can come out on top the fate of
Japan and the entire world hangs in the
balance so let's get into it if you guys
enjoy my videos and you want to see more
in the future leave a quick like and
comment right now it only takes you a
second but it helps me with that YouTube
algorithm and if you are one of the over
50 of people who watch my videos but
haven't taken the time to subscribe do
me a huge favor and make this the video
that you subscribe we are trying to hit
2 million subscribers that would be
insane let's do it finally this video
will contain Jujutsu Kai's and manga
spoilers so please proceed with caution
you have been warned now the previous
chapter was awesome but it ended on an
ominous note the Great Southern Gojo had
a slight nosebleed okay yeah I know in
any other anime with any other character
this would not be a big deal at all but
with Gojo this has real significance the
nosebleed is an indication that despite
being unbelievably strong this epic
fight against sukuna is taking a very
real toll on his body after a grueling
battle that required told you to
activate multiple domain expansions one
after the other to use reverse curse
technique to heal both his body and his
curse technique burnout and to take a
whole bunch of damage from the
incredibly overpowered sukuna Gojo is
feeling the pain at the beginning of the
latest chapter Utah immediately notices
and acknowledges the nosebleed which
tells us that this is an important
detail the mangaka clearly wants us to
pay attention to this but this doesn't
mean that Gojo is about to give up and
be defeated it just means that he's
human and the mangaka wants to remind us
that despite his incomprehensible
strength and confidence Gojo isn't
unbeatable his victory in this battle is
not inevitable even though all of us
Gojo Fanboys want to believe that it is
for now Gojo is still smiling and having
a great time in this fight and he
quickly wipes the blood from his nose as
both he and sukuna expand their domains
yet again at the same time this confirms
that sukun not can restore his burnt out
curse technique with reverse curse
technique just like Gojo was able to do
we're not sure if tsukuna was able to do
this all along or if he literally just
learned how to do it after seeing Gojo
do it once but neither scenario would be
a surprise sukuna definitely has a bunch
of tricks up his sleeve that he's been
cooking up for a thousand years but he
is also able to learn and adapt
extremely quickly so he absolutely could
have just learned how to restore his
burnt out curse technique on the spot
now in chapter 227 Yuta said that this
very concept of using reverse curse
technique to heal your burnt out curse
technique doesn't make sense because
essentially burning out a cursed
technique with a domain is completely
different from taking physical damage if
a machine overheats but it isn't
physically broken it still needs time to
cool down before it can function
properly even if a mechanic can restore
a broken part immediately he can't
magically cool an engine down in an
instant and yet Gojo was able to do the
cursed technique equivalent of that but
we probably shouldn't dwell too much on
what makes sense from a physics
perspective because not only is this a
fantasy world but Gojo and sukuna have
attained superhuman and borderline Godly
levels of power so they don't play by
the same rules as everyone else that is
why everyone watching the fight is
completely shocked at the extent of
their power kusakabe then explains that
within the three minutes that it takes
for sukuna to destroy Gojo's domain from
the outside Gojo needs to damage sukuna
to the point where he can no longer
maintain his domain and as he says this
kusakabe seems to be sweating a little
bit as if he's doubting whether Gojo can
actually pull it off this leads our girl
shoko to say that they shouldn't be
talking as if Gojo is on the ropes all
Gojo needs to do is draw sukuna into
unlimited void for just a few seconds
and sukuna will be incapacitated if Gojo
can somehow destroy malevolent Shrine
within three minutes even once he will
win this and then the next panel we see
is an absolutely ecstatic Gojo preparing
to pounce on sukuna and you can just
tell on Gojo's face that he is loving
this to be fair sukuna is loving this as
well both of these guys are fighting to
the death right now both of them hate
each other and they want to take each
other out but they still have a huge
amount of respect for each other and for
this fight both of them are known to be
the absolutely strongest beings of their
respective eras so much so that no one
could ever pose a serious challenge to
them no one could ever give them such an
exciting and challenging fight before
today as serious as this showdown is for
both sides and as massive of an impact
as the ultimate outcome of this battle
is going to have on Japan and the entire
World these guys are still having a
blast testing each other's strength and
endurance for the first time in their
lives they are both able to go all out
against a truly worthy opponent and they
love it they engage in intense
hand-to-hand combat showcasing their
phenomenal martial arts skills and Gojo
especially looks like he's on a mission
with every attack he is pushing sukuna
closer and closer to malevolent Shrine
the actual physical Shrine that appears
within sukuna's domain and eventually
Gojo throws sukuna into the shrine
itself it was already established
earlier that the shrine within sukuna's
domain seems to be the heart of the
domain rather than sukuna himself this
is highly unusual because every other
domain is centered on the user and all
things that appear within the domain are
merely symbolic but Gojo can sense that
with sukuna things are different that
Shrine is important sukuna tries to push
back but Gojo stays on him and he tries
to inflict even more damage to sukuna's
chest and abdomen area where he was
already injured before however sukuna
protects that area with his hand the
shrine is being literally torn apart in
the ensuing struggle but both men are
still going all out and still smiling
throughout it all then suddenly both of
their domains are dissolved yet again
and once again they are dissolved at the
exact same time everyone is absolutely
stunned by how strong and how evenly
matched these two legendary Fighters are
luckily for us everyone else is also
watching the fight right along with us
so we get some valuable commentary from
the other sorcerers miwa says that when
it comes to fighting within the domain
Gojo is stronger and Yuji watches the
fight intensely as it Dawns on him that
yes Gojo can win as if to emphasize that
very Point Gojo punches sukuna into a
concrete pillar and then the two of them
proceed to expand their domains yet
again by my account this is like the
fifth time they are expanding their
domains by the way and the vast majority
of sourcers can expand their domain only
once a day but go join sukuna are just
built different and they have already
done it like five times within the span
of a few minutes but wait even though
they both appear to have activated their
domains at practically the same time
Utah believes that maybe just maybe Gojo
might have expanded his domain on
instant earlier and Utah is Right Gojo
inflicted a lot of physical damage on
sukunam and sukuna decided to use
reverse curse technique to heal his body
before going on to restore his curse
technique this slight delay in restoring
his curse technique allowed Gojo to
activate unlimited void 0.01 seconds
earlier that's 10 milliseconds earlier
this allows Gojo to further gain the
upper hand inside the domain and 2
minutes and 40 seconds after they
expanded their domains Gojo is able to
punch a hole in sukuna's chest this does
enough damage to sukuna for malevolent
trying to collapse within Gojo's domain
and this exposes sukuna to the effects
of unlimited void even though he's
already inflicted serious damage on
sukunam and even though he managed to
catch sukuna within unlimited void Gojo
is not done he doesn't want to just
Crush sukuna's heart that's just the
bare minimum he wants to destroy his
lungs and liver and bring him closer to
death than Yuji was at the Detention
Center although I do wonder how far Gojo
is willing to go of course he has to
take this fight seriously and make sure
that sukuna is injured enough that he
won't just be able to easily heal
himself but at the same time if Gojo
goes too far he might kill megui as cool
and calm as Gojo is trying to be about
all of this we know that he definitely
doesn't want to kill megumi however
before Gojo can land the finishing blow
on sukuna something massive suddenly
appears before him it is none other than
eight-handled sword Divergent Cilla
Divine General mahoraga the most
powerful shikigami from megumi's 10
shadow
is known for being uncontrollable and
throughout history no user of the 10
Shadows technique has ever been able to
tame it but maharaga impressed sukuna
with its power during their battle back
in Shibuya and so sukuna has clearly
decided to use maharaga in his fight
against Gojo Gojo is clearly surprised
by the shikigami's appearance but at
first he believes that he can take it
out in one shot after all even though
mahuraga is known for its incredible
adaptability it hasn't had time to adapt
to unlimited void so it must be
vulnerable to Gojo's attack
nevertheless before Gojo can launch his
cursed technique reversal makuraga moves
and smashes the ground beneath Gojo
forcing him to jump out of the way Gojo
is stunned to see that mahoraga has
somehow already adapted to unlimited
void and as the shikigami produces of
Rye grin on its grotesque face the
chapter comes to an end bro this was
amazing Gojo just demonstrated Godly
cursed powers and superhuman
perseverance and he managed to get the
better of sukuna the only reason why
sukuna still hasn't been destroyed is
because he had to rely on megumi's 10
Shadows technique which in some ways
means that sukuna is admitting that he
can't defeat Gojo with his own powers
alone that said though how did sukuna
manage to summon maharaga and how did he
adapt to unlimited void so quickly after
all mahuraga does need to be summoned he
doesn't just appear out of thin air and
no one can adapt to unlimited void so
quickly could it be that sukuna is just
so special that unlimited void affects
him differently from other people or
could it be that sukuna is using a tried
and true megumi strategy to get one over
on Gojo we know that megumi sometimes
loves to summon a shikigami before the
fight even begins and then he waits onto
till the best possible moment to strike
and catch his opponent off guard so is
it possible that sukuna summoned
maharaga before the fight even began and
then kept it hidden inside his shadow
this allowed maharaka to adapt to Gojo's
domain before emerging in the exact
moment that sukuna became incapacitated
man I can't wait to see what gege is
cooking what do you guys think about
this incredible fight so far and who do
you think wins out in the end will Gojo
get a clean win will sukuna get a clean
win or will we get some sort of
stalemate and then interference from
kenjaku or Yuji or maybe even megumi
definitely let me know your thoughts and
theories down in the comments below if
you enjoyed this video and you want to
see more Jujutsu Kaizen content right
here on the channel leave a click like
right now and if you watch my videos but
you still haven't taken the time to
subscribe do me a big favor and
subscribe right now we are trying to hit
that incredible 2 million subscribers
that would make anime uproar a special
grade anime YouTube channel feel free to
hit me up on Twitter and Instagram at
animeoutproar thank you so much for
watching and until next time see ya
Space Cowboys